Today's webinar is about using BioSketches
as part of your federal grant application.
Sherri Bailey is going to be presenting.
And Sherri I'm going to go ahead and turn
it over to you.
Thank you, Peter.
Again my name is Sherri and I would like to
thank you for joining us.
Our objective today is to create biographical
sketches for NIH, NSF and DOE federal grant
applications.
Before we really get started let’s have
a quick poll.
One of the things we would like to know is
which federal agency you will be using.
It looks like the majority of you will be
using NIH.
There are quite a few of you here today using
NSF, 13 percent using other agencies, and
some people haven’t decided if they are
going to submit.
Okay, let’s go ahead and jump right in.
SciENcv and My Bibliography are a part of
a free profile service that is part of My
NCBI which is offered by NIH, the National
Institutes of Health.
One of the benefits of a free NCBI account
includes a professional profile tool along
with other great features to use with NCBI
services.
Links will be provided at the end of the presentation
if you would like to learn more.
But today our focus is My Bibliography for
biosketch creation.
What exactly is SciENcv.
SciENcv allows you to document your education,
employment, research activities, and incorporate
your publications, honors, research grants,
and other professional contributions.
A few of the benefits include the ability
to leverage data from existing systems that
you may already use like ORCiD, reduce administrative
burden by creating a document once to copy
and edit for multiple grant applications,
and take comfort in knowing that your documents
will adhere government standards.
When creating a biosketch, you have 3 options:
Create from scratch, duplicating an existing
document and modifying OR using an external
source like ORCiD to import citations and
education.
My Bibliography is a reference tool that helps
you save your citations from PubMed.
If you do not have citations in PubMed, you
can manually upload a RIS file, created by
your citation manager and enter the citation
information using the built in templates.
An additional benefit of using My Bibliography
is that it can generate a public URL to share
your Bibliography with others.
Now that we have a general understanding of
the tools used to create a biosketch.
Let’s touch briefly on how to create an
account to access SciENcv.
There are two ways: NSF users, you may want
to google SciENcv using your favorite web
browser.
From here if you have an eRA Commons or NSF
credentials select the appropriate icon and
and provide your login information.
If your institution is an InCommon partner
or would prefer to use Google for example
click the See more 3rd party sign in options.
The final option is the NCBI icon where you
can create an account to log in directly to
the site which allows you to use the forgot
my password feature.
The second way is to access your My NCBI account
and SciENcv is to go to PubMed.gov or any
other NCBI page and click the log in link
located on the top right which will provide
similar creation and log in options.
After your account has been created or at
any time you can link your 3rd party accounts
such as ORCiD, eRA Commons, HRA (Health Research
Alliance) and/or NSF.
You may also link your account to Google or
your institution (if it is listed) which will
provide additional ways to access the single
account.
Linking is as simple as 1, 2, 3.
To link your account click on your username
located on the top right of the screen, locate
the Linked accounts field and click the change
button, locate and select your institution
or Google and provide credentials.
Another feature located in your account settings
is delegations.
As a researcher, you may not always have time
to manage your account.
My NCBI users can grant access to others to
edit and create documents in SciENcv as well
as add, edit and delete citations in My Bibliography.
Now it’s time for a quick poll.
I would like to know how you will be using
delegations within your My NCBI account.
It looks like the majority of you create and
maintain yourself.
And it’s almost the same percent for those
who maintain Biosketches for someone else.
This is a great option for you to use.
To access this feature, click your username
located on the top right of the screen, go
to Add a delegate, type in the email address
of the person managing your account and click
ok.
The delegate will receive an email which invites
them to create their own account in order
to manage yours.
Now that we have the administration piece
out of the way.
Let’s begin creating a biosketch.
The first time you access SciENcv you will
be taken to the create a new document page.
The form will allow you to: Give the document
a title.
Determine the format of the biosketch.
Select your data source.
Decide if you will be starting with a blank
document, duplicating an existing document,
or using an external source like ORCiD.
Remember ORCiD will automatically import your
biographical and citation data into the biosketch.
Finally, you determine if you would like to
share your document via a URL or keep it private.
You always have the ability to change the
setting at any time.
Once you click create, you are ready to enter
information into the fields.
All biosketches have the following components
in common:
The profile name or title that you created
on the previous page,
The profile type either NIH, NIH Fellowship,
IES or NSF,
The last time you updated the file,
The ability to share,
And over on the right download options and
OMB information.
Please note that NSF documents: the biosketch
and the Current and Pending Support document
only have the PDF and XML versions available
which is a requirement in NSF’s Proposal
& Award Policies & Procedures Guide.
The next field provides your information,
including your name and the linked accounts
of eRA Commons, NSF and ORCiD if available.
Which brings us to the first section of education.
Although the titles may appear different,
and section A for NSF, the data requested
is the same.
Here you will enter degree and training information.
Once the information has been added, the summary
appears on the screen, with the ability to
delete or edit the entry.
This is an example for NSF, but the education
and training fields for NIH and IES Biosketches
appear the same.
You are probably wondering what happened to
Section A for NIH and IES Biosketches.
Here it consists of a personal statement with
the option to include up to 4 peer reviewed
publications.
It is important to note that a lot of the
information can be reused but there are subtle
differences between NIH and IES from NSF biosketches.
Section B requests employment and appointment
information which are also similar.
But NIH & IES requests additional information.
Remember to always read the directions provided
beneath each section so that you are providing
exactly what is requested.
Here is an example of section B for NIH & IES.
Here is an example of section B for NSF.
Section C is where you are able to provide
a description, in your own words, your contributions
to science and add supporting citations.
You will notice in the box below, the ability
to add a link to include your complete list
of published work from My Bibliography which
will appear in your downloaded document for
NIH and IES biosketches.
Section C for NSF biosketches provides a description
of acceptable and unacceptable products and
citations to be included.
There is also a unique element to NSF which
includes the ability to add additional citations.
For section C all of the biosketches have
an add citations box that looks and operates
the same.
The first tab is My Bibliography.
Beneath that, in the blue box, you will see
Add citations.
Add citations will take you directly to PubMed
to add citations to My Bibliography.
When you click on Go to My Bibliography, it
will take you to, yes you guessed it, My Bibliography.
From here you are able to add citations from
PubMed, add citations from a file, which includes
RIS from examples like EndNote and RefWorks,
or add citations manually using My Bibliography.
Once that is complete you can go back, by
clicking on your username located on the top
right, and selecting Dashboard.
You may have noticed that it looks a bit different
from the first time you saw the dashboard.
Yes, you are able to customize the dashboard
to either collapse, move or hide windows.
If you wish to restore any of the items, click
the Customize this page link near the top,
and select the items to restore.
Now let’s continue with the biosketch by
either clicking directly on the document title
or by clicking the Manage SciENcv link.
Once we are back into the Biosketch, it will
look like this after information is added
to My Bibliography.
If you have linked your ORCiD information,
the second tab will populate as well.
We would like to know if you currently use
ORCiD.
If you could take anotner poll, we would appreciate
it.
It looks like the majority of you do use ORCiD.
For those of you who are not familiar with
ORCiD it is a non-profit organization that
provides a unique identifier that distiinguishes
you from other researchers.
So you usually put this on your publications,
but you can also use to put patents and products
that you have created, as well.
Moving on, Section D for NIH and IES is where
you are able to associate your awards with
the biosketch.
For the NIH Fellowship biosketch, awards and
scholastic performance can be added, which
is towards the bottom.
For NSF users you will use a completely different
forma, which is also part of SciENcv, which
is current and pending support.
This is where you add your awards as well
as any in-kind contributions.
Section D for NSF is Synergistic Activities,
which provides a box for free text.
Once the information is entered, you have
the ability to hoover over an entry and change
the position of the text, delete or edit the
information.
Once you have verified the information and
ready to save or print, the PDF links are
available on the top and lower right-hand
side.
As well as the XML, for all users.
The only difference is, again, NSF users are
not able to download the Word document.
If you find you made an error, go back into
your document, make the corrections and resave
or print.
In summary, SciEncv allows you to create and
store multiple documents from scratch, an
external data source or you are able to copy
your form from an existing biosketch of C&PS
form, which is NSF.
You are able to output your PDF or Word document
depending on which one you are using, on demand.
And you have the ability to have delegates
to manage your account.
Documentation about SciENcv, My Bibliography
and My NCBI can be found here.
Also at the bottom is an email address, info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov,
where we welcome feedback, suggestions, questions
and help for any questions that may arise.
Let’s open the floor up to any additional
questions.
[Peter Cooper] Thanks Sherri.
Rana, are there any questions?
[Rana Morris] There are several.
So Sherri, one of the participants in this
webinar is interested in using the bio sketch
but goes directly to funding sources, both
NIH and NSF.
Is it possible through SciENcv to create separate
Biosketches for NIH and NSF and what if they
are applying to two or three grant programs
from either of these institutions?
Can use my bibliography to create multiple
bio sketches.
[Sherri Bailey] Within NSF you're able to
use the PDF which they supply on their form,
as well is the bio sketch within SciENcv.
It's going to be mandated by NSF beginning
October fifth.
The fact that you can interchange the information
because each policy, NSF, as well is NIH has
their own particular guidelines that's why
there are slight differences but we do give
you the ability to share the information.
In order to create multiple bio sketches.
[Rana] Excellent.
A number of people are interested in ORCiD
specifically and they know you can import
ORCiD citations into my bibliography to be
used for SciENcv.
Can you do the inverse, take My bib and reroute
them back to ORCiD.
Is there a better way to do it, is one more
effective than the other?
[sherri] At this time no.
We just import their information.
Were looking at other ways they can retrieve
information from us to make it better for
users.
[Rana] As a follow-up on that.
They want to know if there is a direct [indescernible]
at SciENcv or a possibility to import or export
bib text format in my bibliography.
Do you know about that?
[Sherri] Were looking at that way as well.
If you take all your suggestions and write
to info at NCBI dot NLM dot NIH dot GOV.
The more documentation we have that this is
what people want the faster we can probably
get this into production.
[Rana] Great.
You may not know but is there any particular
place that provides advice for good quality
bio sketches.
What funders are looking for?
I imagine each funding agency might have its
own documentation but there are number of
people who asked about guidance.
What would you recommend in terms of them
finding guidance about how to create a bio
sketch for particular agency or best practices.
[Sherri] I would go back to each agency to
ask your question.
There are specific things they are looking
for.
[Rana] Here is a question.
If you have a current bio sketch and want
to import your BioSketch into SciENcv is it
possible?
[Sherri] It is not possible at this time.
It is definitely something I'm taking note
of.
We will put in front of our development team.
[Rana] And finally, in terms of exporting
bio sketches, are their different formats
for exporting.
Say you finally created your biosketch for
NIH or NSF, what format does SciENcv export
their bio sketches in?
[Sherri] You have the ability for all of them,
either PDF as well as an XML file.
For IES as well is NIH BioSketch you have
the additional word document that you're able
to manipulate.
[Rana] Okay.
Great.
Thank you very much for attending our webinar.
We hope you have a great and safe rest of your day.
Thank you.
[Peter] Thanks Rana
And thanks Sherri.
This is Peter Cooper again.
Thanks everybody and I'm going to end the webinar
I'm going to and the webinar.
[event concluded]